we have three different number lines
here and on each number line they mark
off a couple of these marks this is
negative 2 this is negative 10 negative
5 negative 11 and then we need to figure
out what the blue dot represents and as
a little bit of a hint each mark here is
not necessarily incrementing by one it
could be by more than one so i encourage
you to pause this video and to try it on
your own to try to figure out what
number does this blue dot represent on
these different number lines
so let's tackle this first one so we're
going to go where they give us this mark
is negative 2 this is negative 10 and we
need to figure out this blue one that's
further to the left of negative 10. well
just going from negative 2
to negative 10
how much how what has to happen to
negative 2 to get to negative 10
well we'll have to subtract 8. and so if
we move 2 to the left that's the
equivalent of subtracting 8. so if we
move 2 to the left again that's
subtracting 8 again so this must be
negative eighteen and so if we move to
the left again that also must be
subtracting eight
negative eighteen
minus eight would get us to negative
that gets us to negative
twenty six
now another way we could have thought
about it is if we jump two to the left
and that's negative eight then one jump
to the left is going to be negative four
so you could say well this is negative
four that would get you to negative six
then negative four again gets you to
negative 10 then this would be negative
negative 18
negative 22
negative 26.
now let's tackle this one
so here we're going to figure out this
blue dot here is on the right so if we
started at 11
if we start at 11 you make two jumps to
go to
negative five so what do i have to add
to negative 11 to get to negative five
well i have to add
six
so if i add six over two jumps that
means that each of these jumps that must
be plus three and this one must be plus
three so now each each mark we just add
three so negative five
plus three so plus three is going to get
us to negative two
plus three
gets us to
positive one negative two plus three is
positive one plus three
gets us to
four so here we got to negative 26 here
we get to four
now let's tackle this one
so we're at negative seven or this is
negative seven this is one and then we
figure out this mark right over here so
if you take two jumps to the right from
negative seven to one how much did we
have to add
well to get from negative seven to one
you have to add eight you have to add
eight so then if we make another two
jumps to the mystery number that means
we added eight again so one plus eight
is nine another way we could have
thought about it if we added eight over
two jumps that means we added four on
each jump so this one must be negative
three
add four you get to one
add four you get to 5
add 4 you get to 9.